[Music]
Alana and I are directing for the first
time this season two episode each it's
been really cool oh my god dude
directing has been dope
you let me know if you need anything
okay thanks love you good luck dude
watch me go pretend I just left and go
for it so then maybe we'll get it in
Megatron it's like rap for me to you and
get that mole thing in water ok here we
go goddammit
so when Alana and I write an episode
together we split up ax it's like we're
always trying to make the other person
laugh when we come back it's like see
and so directing we did not direct
together we each directed two episodes
separately but my time in the edit
before it got to Ilana I felt what it
was the same feeling it was exciting to
get to fully develop my vision to like
finish it up and like get to show it to
Alana in the next phase
two of the same thermos oh that's me
same Willy card two soul sisters having
a plan the only mark there's a really
long day than that I was in every single
scene and directing so if you have a
second team which is like stand in for
us so we can set up the shot so we like
how it look something like how the
actions gonna go and then we jump in and
then while you're in the scene you have
to be in the scene as an actor but also
conscious of the whole scene as a
director it's another layer on top of
what we've already done and it's it's
been really satisfying for me and then
in a new way hey Margo can you watch my
stuff first thing I got money to spend
money is a mind control technique that
quantifies the progress of the
patriarchy
yeah watch your stuff okay thanks yeah
hello hello hello Beverly Baumgart
we're here my first day of directing I
directed for ran Derbyshire and Susie
Essman and la blazer my brother it was a
dream in the morning I was like I was
like girl squealing that was like really
easy the typical coverage I could
simultaneously be in it acting and like
feeling what was funny asked him which
were the best Kate's then we got to this
shot that was that 70 show style 360
smoking thing my camera man's monitor
was on the floor so I was watching the
scene as though I was behind and then
once it swiveled to me I was like in the
scene that tripped me out but otherwise
I don't find it that hard because it
feels like we're directing when we're in
it anyway because we've been with our
crew for so long if they can make
certain decisions and have a shorthand
our DP Kristy he's incredible
when we were shot listing for a few
times I'd have to get up and like be in
the scene to like see where I would
picture a camera coming over you know
I'm like pan this way and then you see
it he was like no first we should see it
and then and that way maybe you're right
I'm like no maybe you're right and we go
back and forth and I'm like I think I'm
just inverting it because I'm usually in
front of the camera I'm loving it it's
as though this final puzzle pieces
clicking in for me it takes out a layer
of work that is explaining the
director telling them where are we okay
just real quick pan
catcalling knows it just cuts that all
out it's actually kind of easier in a
way to direct it really is it's easier
to direct your own child in a way for us
[Music]